Russian forces appear to be regrouping
for a possible assault on Kiev
authorities in Ukraine say rocket
attacks have destroyed an air base near
the town of a silky in the key of region
its oil Depot was also hit Russia's
defense Ministry says its Army is
continuing its attacks on a broad front
earlier Ukrainian officials released
CCTV footage of what they say is the
mayor of the city of melito poll being
abducted which you can see at the top of
the screen here
well the latest intelligence suggests
that Russian troops have advanced to
within 30 kilometers of Kiev
sunrise in the capital has become
synonymous with the sound of gunfire
and Air Raid Sirens
these satellite images appear to show
Russian forces regrouping for a possible
assault on Kiev the company that took
them said they also show artillery
firing towards residential areas as well
as burning homes and other buildings
Russia is expanding its military
campaign across other parts of Ukraine
intensifying attacks on cities Under
Siege and hitting new civilian targets
with bombs and missile strikes
residents of this Eastern town have been
forced Underground
I hope that my relatives see me my
sister my daughter and granddaughter my
grandchildren in Kiev and God knows
where else close or far away I don't
know where the war has put everyone into
hiding
those who ventured out of their
basements find their homes destroyed
still they carry on
whoever's life there's hope as we say
as Russian forces move further west
hundreds of thousands of ukrainians flee
their Homeland
but not everyone is able to
the city of Mario Paul is now completely
surrounded by Russian soldiers and
everyone inside is trapped
I say this with pain Mario Paul Remains
besieged by the enemy
Russian troops did not let our Aid into
the City and continue to torture our
people our mariopol residents
we'll try again to send food water and
Medicine into our city
continue to try and
try and Ukrainian officials say more
than 1 500 people have been killed
there is little chance that the
ukrainians inside Mario Paul will see
peace return to What's Left of their
homes anytime soon
[Music]
well for more we can go straight to Kiev
now and speak to DW's correspondent
Matthias Berlinger hello to you Matthias
so we understand that there were Airaid
Sirens again in the morning
tell us what was it like overnight in
Kiev
yeah last night was like any other night
in Kiev there were several times that
the air raid sir Sirens went off I think
it was four times last night uh however
people have gotten used to that already
some people spend the nights the whole
night because of the curfew in Metro
stations uh others just stay in their
Apartments
um so far the the city center hasn't
really been hit badly
um uh there have been a few bombs coming
down on the city in the beginning but
most of the fighting remains in the
outskirts of the city so people have uh
gotten used to some kind of a more
um relaxed fatalistic attitude towards
these air raid sirens and are just
waiting them out
now Matthias are there some indications
that Russia has somehow reassessed its
strategy in the last 48 hours
I believe they are all we are hearing
this from military experts uh one uh
thing that they've observed is that this
tank column that 60 kilometer tank
column that was stuck on their way to
Kiev has been dispersed presumably into
the woods we have also seen some troops
being withdrawn probably also to regroup
and we have seen this intensified
shelling of uh or bombing of other
cities
and and more airstrikes so um it's it
would be it would not be a surprise if
they regroup because their strategy so
far has not LED them anywhere near their
goals but of course we are now observing
and trying to find out what will be next
for the people here in Kiev and in other
cities of Ukraine
well I'd also like to ask you about the
mayor of the city of melito Paul Ivan
federov we mentioned he was abducted is
anything known about his fate or how
he's doing
well this is what you call a force
enforce disappearance and that's exactly
why nothing is known about his fate he
has just disappeared we can only guess
what's happening to him these guesses
would be very bad for him we know that
these that that Russian forces in the
past but also these self-proclaimed
republics that are supported by Russia
and and on which some of the actions
might that are happening now in these
occupy territories are modeled have a
very bad history of torture of
Disappearing people
um and this is most likely what we must
fear for now that he is being detained
somewhere and tortured but we do not
have any information on where and what
exact what exactly is happening the
people of malitopa have come out after
this uh disappearance again and how have
protested the Russian occupying forces
so there is still quite a spirit of
resistance in these in these areas but
it seems as if Russia was going now
almost moving on now to applying some
kind of repressive strategy to keep
these voices down
correspondent Matthias
material reporting
well elsewhere in Ukraine there are
concerns that Russian forces also have
their sights on the city of Odessa in
the Southwest
the key port city on the Black Sea has
so far been spared fighting officials
suggest though the situation could
change with Russia's military planning
to attack by land and sea odessa's
residents are preparing for the worst
with people signing up to defend their
City
well DW's correspondent Alexander for
Naman is in Odessa and she joins us now
for the latest from there
so Alexandra we understand that Odessa
has been targeted by the Russian
military for more than two weeks can you
explain to us the Strategic importance
of the city
well Odessa is a tremendous tremendous
strategic importance for the ukrainians
and for the Russians as well and that
makes the city a likely Russian Target
in capturing odessa's Port Russia would
be able to cut off for Ukraine from the
Black Sea from important trade routes
and we also should not forget that
taking over the control of Odessa would
be a big win from for the Russian
propaganda because this city has a ties
with Russia going back for centuries it
was founded by a Russian Empress
Catherine the Great and many people here
still speak Russian so we can imagine
that the Russian forces or the Russian
government would be trying to present it
as a win for their propaganda however we
also have to say that people that I've
been speaking with told me that despite
those deep-seated connections they're
ready to welcome the Russian troops with
years resistance
right so as we've said many people do
fear that the worst is yet to come in
Odessa how specifically are residents
preparing for the possible Russian
onslaught
well residents that I spoke with that
told me they are ready for whatever may
come and when you look around we are now
in the historic Center of Odessa you see
that the city has been turned into a
fortress where there are a lot of
checkpoints there are barricades build
up a build of sand bags but also metal
and and we also know that there are tank
trips place at strategically important
places here in Odessa and and many here
still hope that you know that it's not
going to happen but of course all of
them are prepared for a potential
Russian assault
and now Alexandra what about just
ordinary life activities are are these
continuing or are shops open are people
going to work
well shops are open schools are closed
we learned that if you for example go
shopping that's not the case that they
would tell you you are not allowed to
buy special Goods however at the same
time we also have to mention that uh
literally almost half of the city has
already left Odessa uh fleeing to other
parties to other parts of the country so
the mood is quite tense but as I said
people here told me that they are ready
for whatever may come next
DW's correspondent Alexandra phenomen in
Odessa Forest Alexandra thank you so
much
well in the 16 days since the War Began
the United Nations says more than 2.5
million people have fled Ukraine nearly
half of them to Poland DW's Brigitte
traveled to the city of shemichul near
the border with Ukraine and she filed
this report
after Escaping The War Zone they're
trying to finally arrives in Poland
hundreds of women and children is
embarked to safety at platform number
five inchemical station
Olga and her two children have been
traveling for three days and freezing
nights they exhausted but relieved to be
getting help the house in khakif was
destroyed in a Russian air raid
we had to take shelter in the bunker and
we were trapped there for days that's
when we decided
it was horrific the children didn't stop
crying we tried to comfort them and try
to stay calm but inside we were also
shaken
they show us blurry photos of hakif the
city in Ruins
their husbands are still there because
they are not allowed to leave the
country
four year old Vanya doesn't understand
why
I miss my daddy we went on the train and
we were going and going and going
in the entrance hall hundreds of
volunteers provide the new arrivals with
food water clothes free SIM cards and
advice
like Olga many don't know where to go
from here know what to do next
every day 5 to 10 trains from Ukraine
arrive here at the station and the
number continues to grow to help all the
arriving refugees has become a major
challenge for the small city of
tremechel which itself has only 60 000
citizens
the city's mayor wat check bakun is
coordinating the humanitarian relief
effort since the war in Ukraine began he
says he hasn't had more than four hours
sleep a day he's proud that his city has
managed to provide help but is worried
he doesn't know how long they can keep
it up we are we are the city hall not
you know Humanity organization so we
will be not to do this for for a long
time or for forever you know just we try
talk with some organization to help us
for a long long period of time
key he tells us is to quickly relocate
the refugees to other cities
Olga has finally decided to continue her
journey to Warsaw before a train leaves
she addresses all NATO States
I want to tell them to impose a no-fly
zone because our families are still
there my parents my brother our husbands
are there I want my family to survive I
want the bombing to stop
Olga plans to call her husband and her
parents she doesn't have the strength
yet because she's afraid they might not
answer
for more we can speak to Chris Meltzer
he's a spokesman for the U.N Refugee
agency the unhcr Chris thanks for
joining us we understand that you've
been on the Polish Ukrainian border for
the last two weeks and we know that up
to now 2.5 million people have fled the
war in Ukraine in your assessment how
many more do you expect
this is very hard to say we have a
planning figure with you on HDR of one
to four million well we have obviously
passed one and also the 2 million recent
figures now I'm almost 2.6 million and
so the 4 million are unfortunately very
plausible but it's very difficult to
predict because there are so many
different factors mostly what's going on
there on the ground in Ukraine how the
conflict will intensify and that's why a
serious prognosis is almost impossible
tell us what the most urgent needs are
of the refugees at the moment
it's freezing code there so we have
temperatures of minus five degrees or
even colder and the humidity also
um it makes it probably the real feel of
the universe so it is freezing cold
that's why we need blankets sleeping
bags we need warm clothes but this is
actually more or less provided now by
the Polish government by by volunteers
and by so many supporters from all over
Europe actually so when I want to take a
look in our unhcr warehouse I see boxes
but with Italian with Spanish but
English with German description
what is most need in the in the now the
near future is actually accommodation
um so because many of the refugees could
stay with relatives and so and and
friends but what's with the people who
don't have friends or relatives and
that's why for the for the next future
accommodation will be the main challenge
well most most of the
in those countries which border Ukraine
and that of course puts an enormous
burden on those countries are there any
discussions about a more organized
process for Distributing the refugees
throughout Europe
well this is a question for for a
European Union not not really for unhr
because we try to provide for the
refugees but we are not there yet that
we really need some some kind of
distribution to All European countries
already now uh some of the refugees um
are going to other countries and you can
see on the and the train stations in in
Berlin and other cities a lot of uh
Ukrainian refugees but this is still a
very small figure
um we had a planning figure of about 70
30 70 will stay in Poland thirty percent
will go to other countries after talking
to hundreds of refugees in the last 15
days my personal perspection is that the
figure is even smaller they're probably
10 15 of the of the refugees would like
to
to other countries most of them are not
staying in Poland but even in eastern
Poland because they hope they came back
home as soon as possible
well you mentioned how many do hope
they'll be able to return home as soon
as possible the reality is that even you
know if the war does end very soon many
areas of Ukraine have been so badly
damaged people's homes have been
destroyed so that that alone makes it
impossible for people to be able to
return to their own homes in the
foreseeable future so
are we looking at a situation where
these refugees may have to stay in other
European countries indefinitely
hopefully not definitely
very sure as soon as the hostilities end
the vast majority of the refugees will
go back so that's what they are telling
me every day as soon as they can they
will return but yes this will be a
challenge not only for a couple of days
or weeks we are talking about at least
about months but um I'm counting here on
the solidarity of the people in Poland
and other neighboring countries and also
in in in in the whole of Europe actually
and I'm receiving everyday literally
hundreds of emails and phone calls from
people from all over the world even us
like United States Canada Japan or
something people are willing to help and
that's why I'm optimistic that at least
in strategy tragedy when you find the
solidarity of the people
Chris Meltzer spokesman from the unhcr
thank you so much for your insights and
also for the work that you do
well now let's have a look at some other
developments in the conflict in Ukraine
German foreign
says Germany will take in 2500 Ukrainian
refugees who have fled to neighboring
Moldova she made the announcement on a
visit to the moldovan Capitol she see
now the small Balkan nation has so far
given shelter to 100 000 people from
Ukraine
the international atomic energy agency
says power has been partially restored
to the Chernobyl nuclear power station
which is the site of the 1986 nuclear
disaster Ukrainian technicians say
they're repairing the plant which was
seized by Russian forces early in the
board
power supply is critical to keep reactor
rods cooled
U.S troops continue to be deployed to
Europe adding to thousands who've
already been sent to support NATO allies
following Russia's invasion of Ukraine
about 130 soldiers left the U.S state of
Georgia the Pentagon has ordered roughly
12 000 service members from U.S bases to
Europe